it's been four long hot months since the
east nusa tengara region has seen rain
is once fertile rice fields are now
Terraces of parched dirt thousands of
hectares in the public Village in the
East Zumba District have been destroyed
by drought
the rain stopped in May this year we
haven't been able to plant anything
since then we need help from the
government we have to ration our food
because the rice that we have is not
enough to consume like on normal days
residents are also struggling to access
clean water with catchments and rivers
reduced to a trickle they have no choice
but to walk kilometers to the nearest
riverbed and take supplies back to their
Village to drink wash and irrigate their
dying crops
I'm worried the drought will continue
for a long time how are we going to live
how do I feed my family
it's a reality acknowledged by
Indonesian authorities it warned that
the El Nino which brings prolonged hot
and dry weather is now affecting more
than two-thirds of Indonesia the impact
is expected to peak in the last week of
September with an even greater risk of
water shortages forest fires and crop
failure
to anticipate El Nino we have tried to
add more rice reserves we have sourced
rice from other areas like West Mercer
tengara and Java Island as well as
importing from other countries
the region is a big producer of palm oil
rice and coffee beans this year due to
the exacerbated Heat and the prolonged
drought Farmers have struggled to
produce a crop
we need more than 30 000 tons of rice
for all the people living in the east
sunba region for a year we are usually
able to provide rice from our own
Farmers Fields but this year we weren't
able to do it again
with these conditions expected to
continue into October the president Joko
wododo has instructed Regional
governments to set aside funds to Aid
those worst hit Sarah Clarke Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera